what if the shen
were to come back
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
yeshen were a very different race of
humans they were more advanced than us
as the tauri but they seem to have
evolved into a species that thought very
differently and acted very differently
than any other humanoid civilization in
the galaxy although very intelligent
practical and perceptive and above all
patient they often lack the emotion that
most humanoid civilizations have and
they are what we would call
villains although at first glance when
you meet the ocean they look to appear
to be
freely giving out technology and
knowledge information and even joining
the hashem confederacy they hold an
ulterior motive and that is to wipe out
any civilization that they come into
contact with and take their resources we
first meet the ashen in the episode 2010
in which sg-1 had met the yoshin we had
formed an alliance with them and
the whole world then knew about the
stargate project and as a result of this
we were given technology cures for
illnesses
we had lots more knowledge about the
universe they appeared to be a
benevolent species that was helping the
human race but it turns out that they
weren't all that good they were
sterilizing the population so that
basically we would all die out naturally
and this is where their patient nature
comes into play their general plan of
attack is to integrate themselves with a
society form an alliance and make
themselves part of that society they
will then do something to sterilize the
population and make that population of
that particular species die out once
that has happened and everyone from that
population is gone
they take the planet and the resources
now this can take a long time
60 70 100 years it doesn't matter to
these people they are very patient and
they will wait now the good news is in
slugger su on the episode 2010
they actually were able to send a
message back in time via the stargate
using a solar flare send a message back
to the past to say do not trust the
ashen
crisis averted however
we then meet the ashen again in the
episode entitled 2001.
we see firsthand what they have done to
another civilization literally killing
the civilization taking all the
resources and building on top of it
using a population to gather resources
to send back to the ashen home world and
in this episode the ashen do indeed try
again to form an alliance with earth
although this is now technically the
first time they've done it because the
first time never happened it's all timey
wyoming wibbly wobbly stuff different
franchise i know but it works now sg1 do
discover the yoshin's plan and stop
the alliance from ever happening and in
fact trick the ishm by giving them a
list of gate addresses that they can
explore
the first address in the list being a
black hole and that is the last we ever
see of them i just hope we don't regret
giving them those gate addresses i don't
think we will
first one being a black hole and all
they get progressively darker after that
now it is presumed that the ishen would
have went to this planet went to the
black hole and destroyed their entire
civilization
however
what if
they are still around
we know that they're a very patient race
we know that they had a confederacy a
big nation of multiple planets they've
taken over over the years
just because one planet got absorbed by
a black hole doesn't mean that the ashen
are not still out there
and they're gunning for blood because of
what we did to them so here's my idea if
stargate was to be renewed if stargate
was to continue a new villain a new idea
could be that the yeshen are back
they've been waiting patiently all of
this time they've been plotting they've
been planning and they are coming for
earth now they're not stupid they will
have seen what has happened in the
galaxy they will have seen the rise and
the fall of the guar wall the
replicators and the aura and will have
no doubt develop new technologies in
order to help protect themselves from
those threats as well they might now
have ships of war with fighter craft
they might actually have
weapons
and they might present themselves once
again as a benevolent race something
other than the ashen and it might turn
out that they are the hashem later on it
might be a plot twist that we find out
midway or towards the end of the first
season just imagine an sg team comes
back having formed an alliance with
another race of aliens who promised to
give us technology and knowledge
and help us with resources it then turns
out halfway through the season that
all the bad things that have been
happening are actually a result of this
new race who are the yeshen who have
just
integrated themselves into this new
society given themselves a new identity
and they are now the main threat will
the terry figure it out just in time or
will it all hit the fan at once and will
we repeat the mistakes of the past what
do you think let me know in the comment
section down below and if you are new to
the youtube channel make sure you hit
subscribe and press the bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching and i
will see you
next week
[Music]
you